prendre les grands moyens pour ajouter
rapidement de la climatisation dans les
chu celle des parce que le système
électrique est trop vieux on ne peut
installer de climatiseurs aux fenêtres
partout il faut donc ajouter ces unités
extérieures complètement autonome nal
fond cette poussée de laffrey dans les
corridors aucun salaire bas les bureaux
dans les chambres un peu partout à fond
sur des otages enfin une bonne nouvelle
au csld notre dame de la merci où des
dizaines de résidants sont morts de la
commune
donc on va retirer puis à ce niveau là
parce que faut savoir que celui des
jours très très long pour nous c'est
super agréable ça nous enlève un poids
sur les épaules même urgence quelques
kilomètres à l'est au ch et celle des
laurendeau de petites unités d'air
climatisé sont livrés depuis des jours
c'est sur le toit qu'on découvre le
principal outil de lutte est la canicule
une énorme unité de climatisation
extérieure représente environ qui
fonctionnait à pleine capacité
un appareil loué pour faire face
rapidement à la crise on a dû louer des
systèmes pour faire des installations
raté des temporaires qui vont être
remplacés par des sit-in permanents
c'est qu'avec la pandémie les emplois
des portes de l'équipement de protection
beaucoup plus lourd et surtout beaucoup
plus chaud oui ajoute l'aja kurt les
gains la visière fait que c'était
drôlement important cette année une
question de confort et de santé pour les
résidents et leur ange gardien
on est plus confortable et réside à
aussi ça nous aide beaucoup
oui je n'ai que du bonheur et les
véhicules et climatisée est installé
québec souhaite que la totalité des
installations soient complétées dans les
ch et celle des d'ici le début du mois
de juillet ici des gentiletti au canada
montréal